meine Damen und Herren wir kommen zu wer
weiß mehr unserem großen Quiz rund unser
rund um unser Spezialthema heute iBlali
und unser Kandidat ist niemand anderes
als iBlali himself wer hätte das gedacht
und wir wollen jetzt mal sehen was weiß
er über sich selbst was weiß ich denn
ich weiß gar nicht über mich selbst ich
habe auch den Eindruck wir haben uns ein
paar sehr schwierige Fragen ausgedacht
ach du scheiße und ich fürchte du wirst
scheitern ja okay ich bin gespannt
aber eigentlich muss es wissen aber ich
möchte du weißt nichts über dich selbst
nee das möchte ich auch da bin ich
eigentlich woher komme ich
jetzt Konzentration okay wir kommen zur
ersten Frage
du bist bereit ja ich bin bereit du hast
auch ordentlich trainiert für dieses
Quiz ja aber natürlich hat sich gut
vorbereitet du hast einfach dein Leben
bis heute gelebt und wir möglichst alles
gemerkt
ist ja klar dafür ist es da okay
wie lang sind deine Videos auf iBlali
zum heutigen Zeitpunkt zusammengenommen
in etwa
153 Minuten
b197 Minuten C 250 Minuten oder
d-278 Minuten okay da muss ich erstmal
überlegen also wie viel Videos habe ich
hochgeladen auf jeden Fall über 50
zusammengeschätzt also meine Videos sind
im Durchschnitt 3 Minuten lang so
ich würde sagen
b197 Minuten möchtest du einloggen
das war leider nichts nein es wird sehr
langsam 250 Minuten aber das ist so das
liegt so nah beieinander ja das ist das
Krise verdammt
okay das nächste war ich bestimmt ja mal
schauen okay doch nicht Steam das ist
ein Steampunk richtig Dingens genau da
sind wir quasi beim Thema in der Steam
Community hat nicht so viel bezahlen
Fanclub wie viel Mitglieder hat der
nennt sich ein Buff heute
hat dieser Fanclub a144
b513c
2007 50 weiß nicht über dich merke schon
oder d15316
du würdest jetzt einloggen
das ist richtig sensationell
doch du hast doch einen gewissen
Schimmer von dir ja also die Community
habe ich einmal gesehen ich habe
wirklich geschaut viele kommen also wie
viele Member ich habe und das waren zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch 120 und ich glaube
nicht dass es innerhalb der kürzester
500 springen kann sehr gut also du hast
diese Fanclub entdeckt sehr gut da würde
ich auch eingeschlafen
okay wir kommen zur dritten und letzten
Frage
wenn man auf Facebook nach iBlali sucht
tauchen einige Gruppen zuerst in der
Suche auf wie heißt eine dieser Gruppen
A
iblaliator
B schwör auf iBlali seine Bratwurst C
blali sind oder D iBlali mit Ei am
Anfang
ich würde sagen
seine Bratwurst also B und du möchtest
das ist auch der einzige Gruppe okay und
da würdest du auch Einloggen
auf iBlali seine Bratwurst und wenn man
beim Fernsehen lernen würde jetzt die
Werbung kommen aber bei uns kommt die
Antwort oder das ist richtig
sensationell zwei richtig beantwortete
Fragen
damit du kriegst den goldenen
klicksumstern die goldenen das ist der
Hammer